[Music]
hello
if you are new to this channel miss
coffee bean sends a warm welcome
otherwise nice to see you again in this
video we will discuss the latest
research trends around the question
of where natural language processing or
short nlp
is heading to and how to really achieve
natural language
understanding you can't
learn language from the radio why not
not even from the huge amounts of text
on the
internet like gpt 3 had access to
no not even then if you want to know why
look at our previous video on this
linked below
where we discuss why a model trained on
text only
cannot really understand meaning but it
can fake it really well
so what do we need to learn language
this paper answers this question by
setting up a roadmap
in five levels called the world scope
the world scope one is the corpus
a long time ago even before i was born
the people in nlp were trying to
exhaustively annotate clean corpora of
natural language this corpora were first
used to reconstruct the language
structure like syntax trees then to
build
word vectors first not contextualized
like
word where apple and apple are the same
or contextualized word embeddings
computed dynamically depending on the
context
do these representations really capture
meaning
the core assumption on the corpus level
is that the context
gives the words their meaning and it is
a very plausible assumption
when someone asks miss coffee bean what
coffee
is she can use other words to answer
like in a definition a hot drink made
from the roasted and ground seeds and so
on
word embeddings like the ones from
neural networks trained on text
are doing the same thing defining words
in relationship to other words
word vectors do not mean anything by
themselves but
get their meaning in relationship to the
other words and their vectors
through vector distances but what is the
limitation of defining
words with other words let's say for
example that you do not know what the
word
seed means then miss coffee bean can
define it further in terms of
other words like bean and this you can
define again
in terms of other words like kidney what
is a kidney a bean-shaped organ
what is a bean a kidney-shaped seed
i hope you see the point sooner or later
one runs into big tautologies
where you defined word a in terms of
word b
and word b in terms of word a
the whole assumption of giving meaning
through context
basically floats in the air where words
help each other towards
meaning but none of these words
do stand themselves on a ground
then what might a suitable ground for
this whole floating construction be
think about how much clearer things
might become if i would show you also a
picture of
coffee while giving you a definition
about it
but images have no place in the corpus
era of nlp
shu go away and here we are
the second world scope the internet
in the era of the internet the nlp field
has been able to make their corpora so
much bigger through web crawling
that only the internet bandwidth the
gpus and
energy are the limit huge amounts of
text make it much easier to think that
context gives meaning to words
language models like gpt 3 can see so
many words in so many contexts
one might not even notice that the words
do not stand on a real ground
and that the language models are only
faking understanding
but we do notice that the impressive
results of the last months with gpt 3
are not that of a big step towards
natural language understanding
how even when important steps are being
made in data sizes and neural network
sizes
only a comparably little gain is
obtained in simple tasks for humans
for example correference is still a huge
problem so the era of the internet has
shown us that size
does matter to solve certain tasks but
this cannot lead us to the goal of
understanding natural language
what to do we might consider calling the
images back
hey images come back here please
so here we are at world scope 3
perception
ah it's multimodal nlp miss coffee beans
favorite level
on this level perception in form of
images and sounds
comes to aids the nlp journey towards
understanding
it should help us in the many cases
where world
knowledge together with the assumption
that we all see
and hear the same world events makes us
leave things unwritten unexplained
if miss coffee bean says okay bye
i have go have a sip of coffee now
we all have a good intuition why she
leaves to drink coffee
she is tired needs the caffeine and
likes the taste of coffee
oh that's strange we know this without
it being
explicitly said but a purely text-based
model could never learn
this if it was never written anywhere
grounding words in their physical
appearance in images would
surely help a machine translation model
to learn that
a ball and ominge are the same thing
but in different languages so we have
seen that there is a lot of motivation
for multimodal learning to marry the
field of nlp with other amazing fields
like computer vision or
audio signal processing all this has led
to great progress on tasks that require
natural language grounding
like visual question and answering
visual common sense reasoning
image captioning multimodal machine
translation and so on
for more details exactly on this area
check out miss coffee beans playlist on
multimodal learning
linked in the description below world
scope 3
is great we gear up machine learning
models with
perception which helps a lot to observe
things
but can we go even one step further what
if sometimes we must wait too long for
something to happen to observe it
we as humans would then interact with
the system and trigger the event
that helps us gather more information
could we also build this into our models
why not and hereby we are already on the
level 4 of understanding
embodiment this means that by taking
actions with a physical body
the system could trigger situations by
itself observe these and act back again
based on the triggered events we would
have a model that would experience how
things act similarly and learn
new words while this sounds awesome it
opens a huge pandora box of yet
unsolved problems when to explore new
situations
when to learn more about the current one
how to plan a set of actions
how to react like how to move a muscle
how to translate these new experiences
and interactions into language
does an experience even need
verbalization or is it common sense
now let's move on to the top level the
world scope
5 the social world while in the stages
before the model would have learned how
to acquire data to have a good
understanding of the world in relation
to the model itself
it still doesn't have any incentive to
communicate or to use natural
language that it understands in the
first place
interpersonal communication is the most
important usage of natural language and
it also makes the most important test
for ai
the turing's imitation game only after
an
agent has learned to use language to
affect the world by social interaction
it has understood not only the meaning
of language
but how to use this meaning to change
the world
but while these five stages stand
apparently separated
with research doing well in stages 1 and
2
well enough in stage 3 and only baby
steps in stages 4 and 5
one has to also understand how
interdependent they are
while chatbots are a thing nowadays we
could argue that we are already making a
huge progress in the fifth
social stage but that is quite not true
while the system is apparently
socializing with the user
it has no understanding about the
communication situation
about the user and his feelings then the
chatbot
also doesn't know about what utterances
are hurtful in general
and which ones are hurtful only for
specific persons
and are playful in other social
situations
the real stage 5 cannot be reached
without having modelled the previous
stages of perception
and embodiment well enough so this was
it miss coffee beans shortened and
simplified version of this paper's
story if she made you curious enough you
can also read the full paper by yourself
as always find the link in the
description below do not forget to like
and subscribe
and share out the content if you want to
support miss coffee bean
okay bye
you